all right we are live on the youtube i'm
dave rubin and we've got another friday
panel extravaganza for you
today we're going to be talking about
how to fix the environment without
anointing
aoc queen of the universe i think
there's a chance
and joining me are founder of the center
for industrial progress
alex epstein author and president of the
copenhagen consensus bjorn lomberg
and president of the american
conservation coalition not conservative
coalition
benji backer guys welcome to the reuben
report hi
thanks for having us i am i'm glad to be
doing this
because uh earth day was this week and
it sort of
got kind of shelved a little bit because
there's just such chaos
happening in the world uh but before we
get into sort of the big issues i
thought i could just ask each one of you
briefly to kind of describe
how and why you got into the
environmental
conversation and do what you do for a
living because i feel like everybody's
always sort of impugning motives when it
when it comes to this so alex i know you
the longest i'll i'll start with you
all right yeah sounds good so you can
probably see behind or you can see i
have my i love fossil fuels t-shirt
uh moral case for fossil fuels is my
book and so yeah my background is
actually as a philosopher i had no
interest in energy no knowledge of
energy certainly no
uh no payoffs by the fossil fuel
industry or anything like that
um and long story short like what i
learned that i didn't know
was how valuable energy is to human life
one
and then two how hard it is to produce
cost effectively by which i mean
low-cost reliable for all types of
machines and then for billions of people
in thousands of places i just didn't
have an appreciation of either of those
and we'll get into
why i think they're so important and i
noticed that when people were talking
about climate impacts which i was
concerned about certainly and i do
believe
we impact climate they were ignoring the
benefits and they were only focusing on
those climate side effects and so my
view is you can't make an intelligent
decision about something
without looking at both the benefits and
the side effects and i found that when i
did that my own analysis
was that the benefits of fossil fuels
going forward far outweigh the side
effects and as we'll talk about
i actually believe fossil fuels have
made us safer from climate so i'll just
leave that as a teaser but it'll
probably come up but i think empirically
uh nobody has ever refuted that so we
will get to that and i should note alex
that
the first time that the mob ever went
after me now it's like old hat but it
was when i had you on that was the first
time that i ever just got
endless endless assault hate and trying
to take me out
and the whole thing so i credit you with
my first mob attack
benji how'd you get into this game well
thanks for having me dave it's great to
be here again
and i got into this because i've been a
lifelong conservative activist
and realized that our side of the aisle
had not been engaging
in climate energy and environmental
conversations in a pragmatic way for
for a long time and we have a heritage
as conservatives uh and
as republicans for doing the right thing
when it comes to the environment
so i felt like we lost our way a little
bit and i'm really worried about some of
the environmental challenges we face
carbon emissions are up 47
since the industrial revolution and uh
you know
the the vast majority of scientists do
agree that we have some serious concerns
to tackle when it comes to
climate change so i believe that we've
got a lot and then on top of that we
have conservation problems and other
issues related to wildlife so i decided
that there needed to be a
right of center environmental movement i
founded the american conservation
coalition which is a
millennial and gen z led organization i
happened to be a gen z myself
i focused on bringing a market-based
smart pragmatic approach to the
environmental conversation
bjorn you you've been doing this a while
i have yeah so look i i was really just
an academic
and i like to challenge my students on
thinking differently and one of the
things i saw was an interview in wyatt
magazine with julian simon
uh an american economist who said look
things are actually getting better not
worse
and that ended up in over three years of
me writing a book called the skeptical
environmentalist
which was really a way of saying look
you think everything is going to hell
you think everything is getting worse
that's certainly the impression we get
from media
but the reality is for most things most
places
things actually getting a lot better
we've seen
dramatic decline just on poverty for
instance over the last 200 years
from 95 of everyone on the planet being
poor
to less than 10 today and that's also
true in almost all other areas as alex
was pointing out
because we've gotten richer and more
resilient and so we need to have that
understanding not to be
scared witless which i think a lot of
people are when it comes to climate
but realizing look this is a real
problem there are many real problems out
there in the world
the world is not great it's just doing
much much better
and what we have to do is to make sure
we do the right things
we make the right policies and don't
just end up throwing lots and lots of
money
on things that'll do almost no good and
unfortunately i just described what
happened with climate also this week
well just one question bjorn so when did
skeptical environmentals come out it was
in the 90s right
2001 yeah so i would just say bjorn has
really been vindicated and one thing we
can talk about is the track record
of catastrophists versus people who
think the world is getting better and so
bjorn i think has the longest track
record of us and so if you look at what
he said back then
he's really been vindicated and many
people that were designated
designating his experts today have been
totally wrong and yet we still think of
them as experts which is a whole
interesting issue
yeah so actually what bjorn just said is
exactly where i wanted to start with
this because i think so much of
of what you guys are fighting from from
slightly different perspectives
is that the catastrophization of all of
this the way that they tell us
in 12 years the world is going to end
unless you let us
rejigger the entire economy and have
complete takeovers of industry and all
that
and that seemingly the way the news
operates on everything
you know was just one catastrophe to the
next that basically makes sort of
sensible solutions
hard would you say that's fair alex
yeah so i have i have a thing i've been
thinking about a lot lately which is
i don't trust people to predict the
future
unless they can acknowledge the present
and i posted
one of my most recent posts on twitter
twitter.com alex epstein you'll see
these four graphs which i think are the
most important graphs i call them the
human flourishing hockey sticks and what
you see is that the different metrics of
human flourishing so how and that's
humans living to their fullest potential
how many of us there are how long we
live how much income we have which
really means how much resource and
opportunity we have
all of those are like this flat for
history
and then they jump up like they go
vertical and so what and
they go up vertically exactly the same
way that co2 emissions
do so interestingly so we can talk about
co2 emissions in the future
but so far co2 emissions correlate to an
amazing
improvement in the livability of the
planet for human beings now it's not the
co2 emissions
it's the energy that generated the co2
emissions because the energy powers
machines
and machines allow us to take this
deficient and dangerous planet
and make it into a very abundant and
safe planet because machines can produce
so much value for us that we can't do
using manual labor so anyone talking
about the future first needs to
acknowledge
the present is better than anyone has
ever had the earth is in the best state
it's ever been
and we have 50 years of catastrophists
saying it's going to get worse so the
burden on them is to ex
is to really explain okay it's getting
so much better how is it going to
invert and everything is going to go to
hell it's you could say yeah i'm
concerned about certain things i'm
concerned about co2
but if you don't acknowledge how amazing
the present is i do not trust you to
predict the future and it shows that you
have some sort of
big bias that's not causing you to see
how good the world is for humans
benji do you find that just that right
there just telling
young people like oh things are actually
pretty good and here's data to show that
humans are flourishing and living longer
and all of the things that both of these
guys have just laid out like do you find
that just getting that hurdle
is basically the hardest part well i
would say that most young people
do not acknowledge the present when it
comes to where we are
in the climate change conversation but i
will say what i think
is the most difficult part for younger
generations that they are that they do
understand
is that the earth is a finite resource
we only have so much
earth to tap into we can only take so
much from our planet
we can only pollute so much uh in our
planet uh and into the atmosphere
and i think that that's what our
generation is really worried about
it's it's the worry that we are taking
too much from our planet and that we are
over developing
and and growing so quickly that we're
basically putting the environment last
and so well i think that there's a lot
of truth behind that
we are where we are because of fossil
fuels and we are where we are because of
industrialization
we also have to look at the future at
the same time and so to alex's point i
think i do agree that we have to
acknowledge the present
which is something that younger
generations have a hard time doing but i
also do think that we have to think
about the future in a pretty substantial
way but to your question dave
just really quickly it is very obvious
that it
that we need action on climate change in
my eyes
it is also very obvious that we will not
get any action
if we allow people like aoc and others
to perpetuate some terrible terrible
ideas
that ultimately harm the planet harm the
economy and
stall any progress so i do think that it
makes it harder to take action
and i do think that we should be looking
at the present as well as the future
yeah bjorn
as the sort of original skeptic on this
let's say
why is it that the scientific community
seems to just not allow
any skepticism related to any of this
well it's certainly a question of saying
group think
uh and we've had that for a very long
time as alex also pointed out
think back to the 1970s people were
telling us that we were running out of
everything that we wouldn't be able to
feed the planet
uh you know in the 80s we were told that
acid rain would
eliminate almost all forests around the
world the point here is to say they were
all grounded in something that's real
and that's also what benjamin
is now talking about there are some real
concerns but then if you
start studying it and you insist on
saying everybody's got to be on the same
team
you end up in a place where you sort of
go off on a tangent and just you know
predict worse and worse things uh so you
know you weren't already in in what was
in 82
predicted that if we didn't get uh
climate change
and acid rain and death certification
under control by the year 2000 it be
like
nuclear war uh no and we know that
yeah we're still here we we've already
established that didn't happen
and we've had lots of those predictions
beforehand so we need to look at the
evidence but it's really really
hard you know you show people this graph
you know i'm i don't i haven't seen your
photographs but one of them
certainly should be we know how many
people die from climate-related
disasters
uh across the world we have pretty good
data at least for the last 100 years
in the 1920s about half a million people
died every year
from floods droughts storms and
extreme temperatures today that number
is down below
20 000 people every year we have seen a
reduction
of 96 percent uh in in uh
catastrophes from uh from hurricanes and
so on
why is that it's not because climate is
not a problem it's because we have
become
much much more resilient when you show
people that graph they're like no
i don't want to see it and that's not a
good way to think and that's of course
because
this climate conversation i worry that
this is not about actually
fixing the climate but it's about
identifying
with something that's bigger than
yourself and oh you know just like the
the grand uh generation had with the
second world war you were fighting
for something real you want to feel like
you're fighting for something but
come on don't we want to fight for
something that actually does good
yeah can i just jump in yeah go ahead oh
yeah just yeah just one thing because i
so my view on what's causing the
catastrophism
is actually i think part of the view
that that benji is espousing is kind of
common sense and that he knows and
everyone knows and i would call this
the delicate nurturer premise and the
idea is basically the earth
is a really great place and then we have
to worry about impacting it and in
general
you hear a lot about okay the world has
a lot of resources and it seems to have
very few threats that's sort of what we
get and then what we do is we deplete
the resources and then we create all
these threats but bjorn pointed out on
the threat side
we're way less endangered by climate
than we used to be and so it points out
the world is not
why it's not a delicate nurture it's
wild potential and actually it gives us
just the raw material for resources it
doesn't give us many resources
and it gives us a ton of threats and so
the number one priority for the earth
being livable
is us being highly productive and that
means using machines
which means using cost-effective energy
and i think this false mental model that
people have of the earth as a delicate
nurture
causes us to be afraid of running out of
things and to be afraid of the earth is
going to bite us in the ass it's going
to punish us and i think you know what
what benji's talking about i pointed out
how
much better the world is getting and
sort of his assumption is oh but now
we've had too much development my view
is six billion people in the world
use way less energy than we do in
america i think the world needs way
more development whether it's fossil
fuels nuclear you need
more cost-effective energy and it's
interesting nobody points out say three
billion people have almost no energy
that doesn't enter the conversation
people are obsessed if a polar bear
moves from one piece of ice to another
so
philosophically i think we have this
assumption the earth is a delicate
nurture
we all also have this moral assumption
that it's bad for us to impact nature
and my view is
it's good for us to impact nature we
should focus on human flourishing and
that would
we wouldn't be focusing on climate as a
top priority at all we'd be focused on
energizing the world
yeah benji i want to get a chance to
respond yeah yeah i frankly just really
disagree i think anybody who's spent
time in nature knows that
it's incredibly delicate and that small
changes can have a very
massive impact i just toured the
everglades la this
this past week where one inch of sea
level rise can equate to
numerous miles of uh the everglades
being
completely destroyed because of that
just one inch of sea level rise how much
sea level rise have we had in the last
20 000 years
how about in the last how about since
the industrial revolution we've had very
a very tiny amount we have hundreds of
feet
since the last twenty so i mean one
thing i would and i don't mean to be
competitive
i think i would just i would just say
like the the point here
is dave was going to give me a chance to
respond so i'd like to have an
opportunity to do that okay we just said
something that was i think incorrect
well
let me let you finish up you said you
weren't scientists i just toured it with
scientists
uh who happen to be uh conservative and
so
i i think i can speak with some validity
here and i was actually down there so
you know take that for what you will um
i'm also in charleston south carolina
right now where they've seen
eight inches of sea level rise just in
the past couple of decades
these changes make up for very big
differences
and regardless of whether or not you
think that
sea levels rose in the past which they
obviously did we are
accelerating those changes and so while
there is a lot that isn't our
in our control when it comes to climate
change there is a sliver of it
in a large enough sliver that it makes a
really big impact in
a glacier area to go from 32 degrees on
average
in a uh in a winter to 32.5 degrees that
makes a really big difference and
whether or not that glacier melts so
this is an incredibly delicate resource
that we live on and we are intertwined
with the environment we are one with the
environment
we rely on the environment for
everything that we do every single day
and so if we destroy our environment we
destroy humanity and there needs to be a
balance
which i think is something you and i can
agree on that there needs to be a
balance
but at the end of the day we don't just
have uh unlimited resources on this
planet
let me just let bjorn chime in on this
because bjorn do you see this type of
discussion which is exactly what i
wanted to have and
and we don't all have to exactly agree
on everything that this is sort of just
like tactical in nature and sort of
where certain people's
um where their sensitivities lie in a
way
well i think it's a lot about our mental
models you know what is it that we're
predicting
and it's probably true to say our mental
models
all of them are likely much much worse
than the best models that we can come up
with
and so in some sense i think the right
question and conversation is really
what is it that the science is telling
us
what is it and and benji is absolutely
right to say look
there is global warming it's made by man
and it will have increases for instance
sea levels will rise
and that will constitute challenges on
the other hand
climate economics also tells us a sense
of
how well can we deal with this and and
perhaps the most obvious argument is to
say
well we have a country named holland or
they want to be called the netherlands
right but
holland that has actually dealt with
this really really
well 40 is underwater and you know when
you walk around there you don't get that
impression it's not like
this is rocket science so just to give
you a sense of proportion
all of holland's protection up till now
has cost somewhere between 5
and 10 billion dollars so over the last
50 years
that's that's not nothing but certainly
compared to the
dutch gdp and certainly over 50 years
it's virtually nothing
and what that tells us is the main
challenge
for most things but not for the uh
everglades was
so sorry where where did you go yeah
southern florida
sorry yes everglades all right but not
for for natural
not necessarily for natural places but
certainly for all human places
what matters is that you don't live in
under corrugated roof and are
really really poor if you're really
really poor you can't afford to tackle
these problems
but if you're a rich dutch person or if
you're a rich bangladeshi as they will
be by the end of the century you can
afford this and so what we have to be
really careful about is
that we don't focus so much on helping
people
through cutting carbon emissions that we
forget that they're much more effective
ways i'm always blown in my mind when
people see
really poor people and say oh my god
these guys are going to be impacted 100
years by climate change
so you know what i'm going to do for
them i'm not going to drive to work
tomorrow
no these guys need you know their kids
in immunized they need
better food they need better education
they need more productivity as alex says
much much more electricity and power
that will make them rich that will also
make them part of the solution
eventually because they will want to fix
the planet
rather than just caring about their kids
surviving so benji i can see you nodding
a lot there so what are some of the
things i mean really what i try to do
with all my shows is give
people some solutions whether they're
political or in this case climate or
whatever like what are some of the
things
that we can do well i absolutely agree
with what bjorn just said and i think
one of the most crucial parts of that is
that we can start to fix this challenge
while also
increasing gdp in in countries that need
it while increasing productivity and
efficiency
and growing the economy i think that
that's that's the balance that we need
to strike that's not the balance that
the green new deal has
and i think a perfect example of this is
this week
conservatives released a climate plan in
in congress
leader mccarthy did about 30 bills were
introduced
by republicans many of which had
democratic co-sponsors to fight climate
change
no air time in the media no air time on
any shows
it actually takes substantial steps to
reduce emissions while not picking
winners and losers in the energy sector
trying to innovate all over the place
plant more trees restore more wetlands
nothing was covered in the media the
left of center side
introduced their green new deal again
and it got a ton of media attention but
guess what the green new deal is it's a
resolution
that has zero policy substance it
doesn't actually
ask for anything to be done so not only
is it just terrible
uh and unfeasible to begin with but
there's actually a real plan out there
to start taking some tangible steps and
also keep growing the economy and
invest in innovation and that's not
being talked about so i think that we
as as people who want a different
climate movement who agree that
we need to do something about it but
that it can't outweigh uh the benefits
of trying to increase
human uh quality of life we need to
start looking at like what leader
mccarthy is proposing what senator braun
and indiana is proposing what these
companies are doing to innovate
because it's going to be innovation and
markets that fix the climate challenge
not government regulations yeah so
speaking of the green new deal since it
was reintroduced this week at this line
that was in there
quote more than 350 million more people
will be exposed globally to deadly heat
stress by 2050
bjorn that sort of sounds like what you
were talking before that we look at
these very distant things i mean 2050 is
not that far off but we look at things
30 years from now
as opposed to kind of looking at now but
but uh alex
you're more on the libertarian side of
this do you think the government has any
role
in doing anything related to climate
well i think it
has to depend on the magnitude of the
threat and then your options for for
dealing with it so i just want to make
one point so i've really stressed that i
think fossil fuels are fundamental to
human flourishing
and that the kind of energy we get from
fossil fuels low-cost reliable versatile
global scale like that's needed
vastly so that that has to be part of
the context i think billions of people
just
lack energy they need much more to live
and so when we're considering co2 as a
side effect that has to be the context
so people think of like co2 is going to
cause a catastrophe i think like
most people's lives today are
catastrophe when they're poor so that's
that's my starting perspective
um i think with co2 you have to decide
is this a big difference between you
think it has a cataclysmic
uh impact you think it has some negative
impact
you think it's pretty much neutral like
i sort of go between it could be
somewhat positive it could be neutral it
could be somewhat negative
i think the benefits far outweigh it and
i think if you look realistically going
forward look at what china's doing
increasing emissions record oil imports
uh you know building three texas worth
of coal plants around the world
they're doubling down on fossil fuels 85
fossil fuel economy
producing our unreliable wind turbines
and solar panels
like the world it is a fossil future to
invoke the title
of my next book in many many ways if you
want to address that i think bjorn has
been great on this point
the only way to address co2 emissions
whatever you think of them unless you
want to go to war with china unless you
think it's a cataclysm where we need to
get in toward china that we might lose
at this point you have to realize the
only way to do it is truly cost
effective alternatives and that requires
innovation and to the libertarian point
it requires liberation the number one
form of energy that has
promised to globally scale is nuclear
energy nuclear has been demonized
criminalized and defunded and you've had
certain people like biden say oh i'm
okay with nuclear
that is not enough it has been
criminalized you need to total reform to
decriminalize it
plus it gets defunded by all these
subsidies to solar wind like the wind
production tax credit
which the new clean future act wants to
extend for 10 years
we're shutting down record amounts of
nuclear has more shutdowns this year
think about this
than every other power source more
nuclear plants the only reliable
scalable no carbon source of electricity
we're shutting down more of that in the
us than anything else that shows you how
screwed up our policy is
so i'm for liberating uh everything if i
did believe that co2 was going to bring
an end to the world yeah i'd say we have
to have a world war but i don't believe
that
fortunately we don't have that kind of
tragedy and fortunately climate is
getting safer so whatever's happening
negatively with co2
we're outweighing it just by our ability
to adapt so
we should be focused on more energy and
liberate nuclear yeah bjorn i want to
let you jump in on that
so so david and this really also goes to
alex
um alex tells us that china gets 85
of its energy from fossil fuels but
let's just remember the rich world gets
79
of its energy uh for from fossil fuels
we're so virtuous seeking and we're you
know signaling with all our
wind turbines and solar panels but most
people would not want to live in a world
where they can't get a lot of cheap
power very quickly
and and so the reality is unless you
face up to this
that not only are we not willing to have
this but the vast amount of the world
wants to have what we have
that is only possible through innovation
if i can just give you you know sort of
a
quick metaphor we've been running on
metaphors right but if you look back in
the 1950s in los angeles
it was a terribly polluted place mostly
because of cars
uh and and you know this sort of
standard approach to dealing with
climate change today
would have tried to deal with the los
angeles air pollution by saying to
everyone i'm sorry
could you could you stop that car thing
could you you know go running or
biking instead and of course they would
have had zero success what did solve
much of the problem not all of it much
of it was the catalytic converter
somebody innovated the catalytic
converter in 1974.
you put it on your tailpipe yeah it
costs a couple of hundred dollars
it has real cost but then you have
almost clean air you can drive much
longer pollute much less
that's what we need and nobody is
focusing on what will actually work you
know biden had this big
summit this this week and it was
basically just the same thing as what
we've tried the last 30 years
lots of leaders get together they say
all these beautiful things
about what they're going to promise in
10 15 50 years from now
and then they don't do it that's
surprisingly not the way to fix the
climate
the way to fix the climate is to find
technology
that's so green technology that's so
cheap that could be
uh you know nuclear power that's the
fourth generation nuclear that's so
cheap
it could be fusion it could be lots of
other ways it could be solar and wind
with batteries
but the whole point is if it's so cheap
that it's cheaper than fossil fuels
everyone will swim everyone will do it
yeah benji do you find that young people
are kind of open to that they're like oh
yeah like
joe biden is probably not gonna solve
this and aoc is probably not going to
solve this like maybe a guy like elon
musk might have a little more to do with
it or just that
like there's some cool things out there
that are different ways of thinking
about solutions look that's the biggest
missing link
in american politics in my opinion right
now is the lack of knowledge within
younger generations of what it will take
to solve what they perceive as a climate
crisis and what we know of as climate
change
we decide if you believe in science and
i believe in science the science says
that we don't have
all the technologies to fight climate
change so what does that mean
we are going to have to create we are
going to have to innovate we are going
to have to as bjorn pointed out
make energy production and other climate
solutions cheaper
than the alternative and the only way to
do that is in a competitive marketplace
in a capitalist marketplace
with the government with a limited
government uh
outlook so i think young people need to
be exposed to that because they care
about this issue and they care about it
with good faith
they do want to protect this planet they
do want a brighter future they do want
green jobs clean jobs and they and they
want to fight for the future generations
and their generation
but we need to connect with them about
what it will take to do that
and if you trust the science it says
that we need to innovate
so let's innovate benji i'm going to let
that be your closing statement alex
give me something positive on the
innovation side because i know you want
you want machines to do things
you want human innovation to do things
like what can we look at
i mean the thing i'm really working on
is coming up with the nuclear
decriminalization
platform so i just say positively it's a
focus of mine i think that's really the
missing link i mean you can talk about
all sorts of things could do things but
if you look at why are fossil fuels
successful
they're naturally stored naturally
concentrated naturally abundant
the only other source with those
attributes even more so is nuclear
material
so i think nuclear is uniquely promising
we have a lot of promise from the past
before is criminalized so
i'm in favor of that and if people want
to know more go to
energytalkingpoints.com i have a lot of
info on that
and other issues yeah and we're going to
link to all of your
stuff down below don't worry we're we're
a professional operation over here
bjorn give us some hope give us some
hope because you've still got a smile on
your face after
doing this for a while and being a
skeptic and being called mean things and
all that stuff
so i i wrote a period uh article uh
for last year that tried to summarize a
lot of this argument
and and if you look at what is the best
knowledge of what the
future impact of global warming will be
it will be slightly negative
so the uh climate economics you know the
the only guy who won the nobel prize in
climate economics william north house
estimate that by
the end of the century global warming
will cost us somewhere between three and
four percent of gdp
wow that's not a trivial number but and
here is the hopeful bit
the un also has to plot out so how well
is the world going to be
you know because that depends on how
much emissions we're going to have
what they tell us is in their most
likely outcome
each person in the world will be 450
as rich as he or she is today so what
global warming means is instead of us
being 450 percent as rich
we will only be 436 percent as rich
yes it's a problem no it's not the end
of the world right
this underscores the point here let's be
sure
to fix this i would love to leave the
world 450 instead of 436
but we have to be very careful not to
undercut that
by making solution cell costs at 10 20
30
instead so you know don't cut off your
arm to cut to cure your wrist ache
make sure you make smart decisions and
that's all about investment
in research and development of the green
energy well listen guys it was a
pleasure talking to you and you know
this is just i want to do more on the
environment in general i felt like this
was kind of the right week to do it not
only because of earth day but
also because there's just such political
chaos and i i didn't want to
only focus on that so i'd love to have
you guys all back we'll do solo
we'll do together and you're all doing
great stuff and again the links will be
down below so i thank you guys
and i'm gonna finish up solo so have a
great weekend guys
and for everybody watching uh if you're
hearing a little bit of
hoarseness in my voice we did a live
meet up last night for the reuben report
locals community
in orange county uh actually our our
guest this week andrew gruel
who's the uh the owner and operator of
slapfish restaurant group uh he hooked
us up
and we had about 70 people come and we
drank a lot
well i drank a lot of tequila people
were drinking all sorts of other stuff
but
uh we went around the room it really was
like one of the most enjoyable nights
i've had probably
uh in a year or so we went around the
room about 60 70 people
just introducing themselves saying just
one or two things about themselves very
briefly
and people were exchanging phone numbers
and
people were talking to each other and
breaking bread with each other
and realizing that things aren't so
crazy and you're gonna not believe this
this one you just won't believe this
there were there were gay people
there were straight people they were men
they were women they were black people
they were asian people there were white
people
nobody punched anybody we all agreed to
disagree on some things i mean people
were getting into political arguments
and it wasn't even political people were
just having a blast it really was
an absolute pleasure so to any of you
that were there last night i
thank you it was really a true joy but
truly i you can hear it i'm
the voice is hurting but i only have one
more show that i have to do today so
i'll be okay
anyway the reason i mention all of that
is get out there and see real people i
think one of the things
that's happening right now this has
nothing to do with the environmental
conversation we just had
but like the way we are cutting
ourselves off from people and just
doing it online just chatting with
somebody and just zooming with somebody
and face time with somebody
it ain't enough we're social creatures
and social media has somehow made us
less
social so get out there and don't be
afraid of people i think that's going to
be the next psychological hurdle
that we're all going to have to get over
i think people are really afraid
of people now and right before we
started the show i showed my guys
somebody tweeted out
i think it was robert barnes tweeted out
a picture of a woman
at a supermarket and she's wearing a
mask okay
but then she's got two dogs in her cart
and the dogs are wearing masks
you see what we're doing to people we're
making everybody crazy man
it's just it's just nutty so anyway i
hope you have a great weekend i hope you
see some people you like maybe even some
people you love
i hope you don't spend too much time
online we'll be back at it monday and
man i really i gotta
i gotta take it easy from talking for a
little bit all right have a great
weekend everybody